so let's take a look at our print and
see what is the difference between the
previous incarnation the x/z class
versus this class you should have gotten
a copy of these with the registration
packet but let's talk about them here we
have a front and the side view this is
our straight to access part that we did
in the previous class and we've added
quarter inch by quarter inch holes at
the quadrants on the OD of the part
we've added four 632 holes that are half
an inch deep and we've also added a
milled hex across the front of the part
so these are going to be the focus of
the c-axis class and I think they're a
good representation on what is possible
without having a y-axis but being able
to use milling so let's look at some of
the processes that we'll be using we do
have the live milling face cycle that
we'll go into in depth we also have a
live face drilling canned cycle that
should be in the packet you got sent as
well as the live tap there was a little
busy
there we go the live tap face cycle so
we're low will go all over but I will go
over all of those as we need them but
let's focus on what we need to do now to
make our machine ready for this advanced
part ok so we're right back at our
machine I'm gonna go ahead and take a
peek inside the front door of the
machine so that you can see we have the
tools that were remaining from our two
axes part but we've added an x-axis
drill for the four quadrant holes we've
also added a live z-axis end mill as
well as the drill and the tap as we
previously mentioned in the two axis
class I've grouped like tools on their
respective sides of the turret as you
can tell now that we have z-axis working
tools right next to x-axis working tools
we could have some interference issues
so I made sure that since I did not have
the ability to skip a skip a pocket skip
the turret station in between these two
tools I just positioned the shortest
available z-axis working tool to
position next to the stick tool this
should prevent this tool from contacting
the jaws as they're spinning so I
populated my my turret with these new
tools most of them there's our tap most
of them are not going to require
anything for the nose comp section if
they're a drill or tap obviously we
don't have any compensation factor to be
used however when we get down to tool
number 9 which by looking at our tool
list you see that station number nine is
our live z-axis half inch end mill we
are going to want to be able to comp
that tool and I also don't have the
benefit of a cam system that will
automatically compensate for the
diameter of the tool so to ease my
programming I'm putting the full radius
value of this cutter in the nose comp
column so on nine which is as we already
talked about the half inch end mill put
a quarter inch in both the X and the Z
column and previously when we did nose
radius compensation we had a p-value
here to represent three for a turning
tool two for a boring bar for an end
mill we're compensating from the center
of that tool so our p-value for an end
mill could be either zero or nine they
both mean the same thing they both mean
we're compensating from the center tip
of the tool
and our side action drill it's just a
drill we don't need any any compensation
for that so now everybody is all set in
terms of the the tools I do want a
stress let's go back to looking inside
the machine I do want to stress that
these tools we want to be gauged from
the the center the x0 on these tools we
want to have absolutely right in the
center of the of the tool if you don't
do that particularly on the end mill you
will find that our our tool path will
not be correct our flats won't be
straight across because the machine is
utilizing the tool center line as the
the offset for the part so worst case
scenario if you don't already know what
the x0 is for one of your live tools
feel free to touch the OD of the tool
off of your preset er to get an initial
value and then make sure that you
subtract if you touched on the OD side
of the setter or add if you touched on
the ID side the entire diameter of the
cutter why isn't it going to be the
radius of the cutter if we're just
moving to the center x-axis is always in
a diametrical value until we turn on a
milling can cycle so if you are gonna
touch this off the OD of the part or off
of your preset er make sure that once
you have the calibrated value you add or
subtract the entire diameter of the
cutter and that will put your x0
centerline at least close to where it
should be and then once we have a result
from the part we can we can adjust from
there also before we before I forget to
mention it to you the biggest mistake
that I see people making when they're
milling in C axis
they you measure your part and you find
that you need to adjust your offset ever
so slightly with every other tool in the
world you're using the X offset value to
adjust don't do that when you're milling
adjust here at the nose radius
compensation value so if you find that
your your hex is 5 thousandths oversized
you'll put the minus value in the X and
the Z column instead of where you
normally put it with a turning tool
which would be the offset column the
there was one other thing I wanted to
mention Akuma offers what they call
negative tool radius compensation as an
option for most machines we've gotten to
the point these days where most of the
sales guys will they know that this is
an important value and so they'll add it
to the machine automatically but the
negative radius compensation value is
let's say for instance we utilized a cam
system to to generate our code and so
the cam system automatically built in
the compensation for the diameter of the
tool or the radius of the tool if that
is the case and all of a sudden I find
that I have to minimize my or I have to
reduce the size of my hex by let's say
five thousands I had to go negative on
that value if you do not have the tool
nose are the negative tool compensation
option on your machine this will
actually make the part larger yeah a
little bizarre huh
so negative compensation is an option
and if you find that you're fighting and
you can't seem to get the get the
machine to make the part smaller by
putting a negative value in there give
your give your sales guy a call and find
out whether or not you have the negative
comp option and if you don't you can
always get it filled installed that is
the the rationale behind this is that
Akuma expects you to do this which is
put in the radius of the cutter in your
nose comp column and by using that as a
philosophy there is no negative tool if
you don't have a tool at zero but
anything negative means that there's no
tool in there and by doing this you have
the ability to make the thing smaller or
larger confusing right anyway now we've
done all the preliminary that we need to
do with our machine so let's move on to
our program in our to access class we
covered several of the editing features
that Akuma gives us on the machine so in
keeping with that let's let's use a
couple more of the tools that Akuma has
built into their control right here I
have the the two axis program that we
used for the class I don't want to
overwrite that because more people will
be coming through this class in the
future so but I would like to have all
of the two axis code available to me so
I'm going to make a copy of this so that
my source code my original will still be
intact but I can add to it for the class
so by highlighting the individual file
name I have a button here for copy by
pushing f5 copy it gives me the
opportunity to change the name
which is of course something I want to
do in this case I don't want to
overwrite the original we'll call this X
ZC class and as I mentioned in the the
two axis class one of the biggest
mistakes people make when they're
creating a program or copying it over is
they type in the new name once they get
done with it they get all jolly and they
hit the hit MD one copy or they try to
terminal eyes this copying process
without touching the input key I have to
hit enter which takes the code from the
input buffer and puts it into the file
name if you don't do that it's gonna try
to copy over with the existing name but
of course that that program already
exists so now it's asking me where do I
want to copy it I could copy it to one
of my USB drives if I chose or the
terminal connection which is an Ethernet
connection from your machine to the
office network but in our case we want
to drop it into the Machine directory 1
or MD 1 so as soon as I touch it it
creates the new program with all of the
existing text from the previous the
previous two access class and so we're
just going to
drop down to where we want to start
inserting code and we will believe it's
right there
yeah right before the cutoff and now
it's just too so that I don't get lost
as to where I'm adding text I just added
a bunch of lines here so it'll make it
easy for me to jump right in and start
creating the new code there's another
feature that we didn't talk about during
the c-axis iris or the XZ class if I
wanted to save this I've just made
changes I want to save it but I want to
keep editing and the impulse is just a
hit quit stop it'll ask you if you want
to save if you say yes but now you have
to go back in and open that same program
there's a little two-step process there
that's not wrong you can certainly do it
anytime you want but if I wanted to save
this program and continue editing I
could arrow over and now I've got a Save
button
so I'll just tap that I have the
opportunity to change the name if I want
to I do not so I'll just it okay it asks
me Ivana overwrite
yes I do and now I've saved all my
changes and I can continue on with my
editing this is also very handy if you
make a mistake there I just made a
mistake I've got a whole bunch of
gibberish on here and if I think oh geez
I didn't want to do that I can always
quit stop do you want to save no I don't
so now I've dumped those editing
features those edited features which is
just one more reason why I like the Save
button because once I have added a block
if I'm happy with that code but I want
to resurrect my undo I will tap the Save
button and save the program all right so
let's move on before we start any of our
live tool drilling cycles I'd like to
show you a parameter that we
gonna want to make sure is set properly
on everybody's machine so if you reach
up and touch your parameter button it's
on the machine control it'll pop up with
the common variable page that's
perfectly normal we want to do f8
display change and we're looking for the
parameter that's labeled multiple
machining again I've done this a couple
of times in some of the other classes
but let's make sure if you don't see
multiple machining here use the arrow
right button while the display change
screen is up touch menu change and make
sure there's a check mark in all display
that will make sure that your multiple
machining is showing and when I touch it
and hit close now these are the
parameters that relate to all of the
live drilling cycles and the one I want
to address is the multi cycle return
point what this is it's the default
value for the machine to return the tool
prior to indexing to a subsequent halt
wow that's that's confusing as all
get-out basically it's where to put the
tool after you're done drilling before
moving on to the next hole and in
general the factory likes to send these
things out with the parameter set to
cutting start point which means if if my
tool is delivered to a quarter inch in
front of the part and that's where we
execute the drilling cycle however we
say hey the tool is not going to be
touching material until it gets to Z
minus 120 this parameter set to cutting
start point will only pull the tool out
of the hole and then index to the next
the next feature which is a little scary
if you're inside a counterbore or
something that you have to retract out
of in order to
in order to not break the tool during
indexing so I suggest to everybody that
when you get your machine you start
playing around with it go to display
change in parameters find your multiple
machining and we will set the multi
cycle return point by touching f1 menu
and change it to cycle start point what
this is going to do is regardless of
where the tool touches material it will
always return that tool to the initial
point where was the tool delivered prior
to calling the cycle so in the example I
just gave where we delivered the tool to
z+ 0.25 but we didn't start cutting till
minus 120 this means that after the
first hole it will make sure the tool
comes back to positive 0.25 before
indexing to the next hole that can save
you a world of hurt once that's set one
time you never have to deal with it
again it's a modal thing just check it
and you will avoid some broken drills
all right so let's take a look at our
three axis process plan see exactly what
what we're gonna do first so all of
these operations from 1 to 8 were
already completed in our to access class
looks like we're moving on to the face
drill let's take a look at our print so
that we can see exactly what we need
appears that we've got four holes there
on a one inch bolt circle and they're
half inch deep but we are going to keep
in mind that they are going on this face
that's 120 thousands from our Z zero so
we'll pay attention to that as as we
start to program the the depth all right
so our first our first live tool call
we're going to use pretty much the same
structure that we used previously we're
gonna start with a sequence just like we
always did and since we're using tool
number 6 as our 110,000 diameter Livesy
drill we'll start with n 6 get the
cursor out of the way
and in keeping with our format we'll
throw in the G zero because we know we
want to be in positioning mode no matter
what and cancel any cycles that are
currently active previously we were
using G 95 inches per revolution
programming however now that we're using
live tools we want to use G 94 for
inches per minute programming and then I
always add in an m5 mainly because I did
not turn off the spindle the main
spindle from the turning evolution that
happened before and by doing it now then
the machine is in the status to be able
to activate C axis mode if the spindle
is rotating when you command the C axis
M code it will generate an alarm on our
next line we will repeat the process we
did before of saying another sequence
number just in case you have the tool
restart feature on your machine and then
we will call up tool 6 offset 6 so this
is a drill and we're not worried about
radius compensation we don't need the
first two digits we'll just call up the
first two as being the turret position
the second to being the XZ offset and
because I like to be nice and clean
we're going to put in a word description
of what this is live drill and I like to
put in a size as well just in case I
have to send somebody over to replace a
tool for me they can see just by looking
at the program exactly what size the
individual drill is and then we'll turn
on our coolant now on our previous
statements let's take a look right after
the tool call we have a positioning move
but we put that in on a standard turning
cycle because the spindle was already
rotating that's not the case in a life
tool we've got it turned off and this is
probably one of the more dangerous times
when proving out a program is when the
tool is positioning from its turret safe
position too close to the part and I
always like to have the spindle rotating
during this time just in case there's a
slight bump
there's a less opportunity for damage to
the life tool if it's rotating when
something nasty happens so we're not
going to move the tool just yet we're
going to enable the c-axis mode through
m110 and in case you forget that we'll
call up our three access M codes and
right down here at the bottom and 110
c-axis Connect that's on a line all by
itself in my format but now I am ready
to fire up the live tool and let's call
up that M code list again so that you
can see M 12 13 and 14 are my live
tooling spindle activation codes so
we're gonna do em 13 for spindle
clockwise and now I'm gonna have to give
it a speed but here we're gonna do
something a little different when we did
the main spindle it was say s 4,000
that's a 5,000 charlie that's 4,000 well
Akuma doesn't want us to mistake turning
on the live tool with turning on the the
main spindle on this particular machine
I have 6000 rpm available for the live
tool and I don't want to accidentally
put in s 6000 and have the main spindle
go so they've changed the code up a
little bit for the live tool instead of
being m13 s 4000 it is M 13 SB equals
that stands for spindle B equals 4,000
rpm so any live tooling Okuma machine is
going to use SP equals as rotating the
the tool instead of rotating the part so
that's a good one to keep in your in
your data banks now that we've got the
spindle rotating now I feel free making
my motion to X 1 point 0 Z oh let's go
to say quarter inch from the face of the
part and at the same time I'm gonna
orient the C axis so that the tool is
ready to go to its first hole now I
chose going to X 1 inch
simply because that's where the hole is
going to be drilled and so there's no
real reason to go to an X clearance
plane particularly since this Z is a
quarter inch away and that should make
everybody comfortable as the tool is
wrapping down to the face of the park ok
so now we're in position
and we've got our spindle rotating I'm
ready to look up what my my cycle is and
from my g-code list you'll see that it's
g1 83 so I'm gonna grab my g 183 cycle
document and it's in the same format as
the ones we used in - axis where it
tells me okay move to the tool clearance
plane or home position tool the cutting
position shift into milling mode yes yes
yes we've done it all and then we're
gonna call the cycle g1 83 with some
awesome codes and here is the
explanation of the g1 83 cycle that's
taken right out of the manual very
similar to the G 73 and G 74 that we did
in the two axis program we have the
ability to do a combination of short
retract and long retract so it's
basically a combination of two cycles
into one and our format let's go ahead
and key in g1 83 as our our specific
cycle and I do have to repeat where the
X is even though I'm still sitting I'm
already sitting at that position I do
need to repeat it so that the machine is
clear that this is truly where we're
doing our hour this is the diameter of
our boats bolt circle so I have my X now
I want my Z in there and the Z on this
compass particular part let's take a
look we know that where is it there we
go we know that it's half-inch deep but
we're 120 thousandths already into the
part so my minimum thread depth from Z 0
is going to be minus 6
what 620 there we go so I want to make
sure I drill beyond that let's go
let's give it a hundred thousands of
drill tip clearance so that our tap will
do very well when it goes to the bottom
and we'll give it a C zero because
that's where we're currently located
now our K value this one takes me a
little bit to explain to customers but
the K value is expressing where the tip
of the tool is right now in relation to
where the cycle is going to start so
let's call back up our G eighty-three
and hopefully they show us there we go
right there
q2 or the K value is a an absolute I'm
sorry it's an incremental but positive
value from where the tool is now to the
top of the material so we know that our
material is 120 thousands below the zero
and we're 1/4 up from the from the top
so if I wanted to just start pecking
from the 250 and I didn't care about the
air I'd call it k zero because that
would that would just start pecking at
my increment from where the tool is now
however I want to save myself a little
bit of time so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna put in a K value that causes the
cycle to start something below where we
are now and let's just say we're gonna
go K point let's go
250 and then 126 3 let's go let's just
say that k 250 so it's going to start
pecking at our Z 0 and we'll have an
opportunity to see how it how it
functions before before it actually
makes contact with the part and next
we're going to do the L value which is
you see here the L value is the depth in
between retracts so let's just give that
an elbow point 2 5 and our actual amount
of bite per Peck let's give it a little
different value so now it's going to do
a hundred thousands per bite but it's
going to do a full retract after every
quarter of an inch and the last is a
feed rate F 20 let's go 20 inches a
minute there is a provision in this disc
and cycle which will allow us to do a
number of holes but I'm not gonna use
that right this second I'm going to show
you the longhand method we know that a
canned cycle is what they consider modal
so until we cancel that cycle every
position that we specify after this this
initial call will repeat these exact
parameters so I have my hole at C 0
let's make another at C 90 another at C
180 and another at C 270 now that'll be
all four of my holes and to cancel the
cycle I'll use G one eight zero and then
I like to put in a rapid to a clearance
plane just so the thing will move away
from my part and not scare me to death
make sure that you put in the m12 to
turn off the spindle I'm could also if I
wanted to I could put that on the same
line as the the motion just doesn't
matter but it's a matter of preference
and then I will cancel the live tooling
the C axis connect mode
you don't have to do this if the
subsequent tool is also going to be a
live tool however it can cause problems
when you're trying to restart are you in
c-axis mode are you not in c-axis mode
it becomes confusing so I like to turn
it on use it and then turn it back off
now our motion to home will be the same
as it's always been
x30 z10 and ake a an optional stop so
that we can pause the machine if we're
proving out the program it won't just
continue on so let's take a look and see
how we did
we will select that and now we'll go to
our back to our main operating screen
make sure we're looking at the graphics
and we'll do a skip to get forward get
through the two axis turning will skip
right to our next tool once again I'm
going to go for the large screen of the
animated simulation so that we can see
what's going on we'll turn on our
program so that we can see it now we'll
use the restart
we'll select n 6 because that's tool
number 6 make sure that I turn on my 3d
graphic during drawing and press ok so
now we're zipping through the two axis
stuff that we did previously and when it
gets to my drill it will pause waiting
for me to push sequence restart now I'm
gonna get rid of the trace lines just
because right now it's a little busy but
keep in mind that if you want to see the
difference between a rapid move and a
feed move the trace animate is a really
good one to do that so we'll hit our
sequence restart it is now positioned to
turret and the machine in a condition
that it would have been in if we had run
the program normally up to this point
and now we can press the cycle start
button and here comes our drill doing
the combination of short retract and
long retract and drilling our holes now
some of you may have noticed that hey
wait a second what's going on here even
though we commanded C axis motion the
graphic was showing us moving the tool
well the reason behind that is because
the the software for the graphics will
never move the part it'll move the tool
but the machine itself will be moving
the moving the part around so to display
that I'm going to go over to my
collision avoidance page and let's let's
see if we can get a good angle here move
this over that that'll probably be okay
we may have to we may have to do a
little bit of a there we go we'll give
it a bit of an isometric view there so
that we don't we don't get our vision
blocked by what's going on and now we'll
do our cycle start now we'll do a little
SuperSpeed action okay so now we're
ready to see this our part is complete
from for two axis and now we'll hit
cycle start now you'll notice that
instead of moving the tool around the
machine is behaving as it actually will
rotating the the spindle however the
special function graphics again just it
will never move the part so we just
understand that the C axis is moving not
the not the X so let's take a look and
we are believe we are happy with the
z-axis live drilling portion so now we
can move on to the next process which
will be tapping so now let's go back and
take another look at our process sheet
and see what comes next looks like we're
doing the face
tap action let's get back in here and
edit our
program because the g1 84 or live rigid
tap cycle is so similar to the z-axis
drill we could literally copy this
entire thing over change this to do to a
g1 84 modify a couple of our values here
in the cycle line and be done with it
but I'd like to take this opportunity to
show you a couple of different options
that are available so just as I
mentioned I am going to copy everything
but once we paste it we're gonna make
some changes there we go
obviously the first change should be to
change our tool which in this case we've
decided our tool number is 5 and 5 and
once again no no radio compensation so
four-digit number is just fine we'll
call this the live 632
tap and we still do our m110 and 4000 is
gonna be way too much for for the a cell
D cell to keep up with the the inertia
of the machine so let's knock this down
and call it 250 rpm we can probably do
more than that but let's keep it light
for right now and our motion can still
be exactly the same we're gonna start by
talking about g1 84 okay so this is a
this is a point of confusion with an
awful lot of Akuma
owners if you look in the manual you'll
see that there are two face tapping
cycles g1 78 and g1 84 and sigh well why
do you have two of them well the machine
is designed to have one cycle for rigid
tapping and a second cycle for floating
tapping and the the factory has
designated 178 for the rigid tap and 184
for the floating tap
however they realize that we like to do
our we like to associate anything with
that ends in 84 on a g-code with a
tapping cycle so I'd like to show
everybody a real quick parameter that
we're gonna want to check on your
machine before you decide which which
code to use so by touching the parameter
button going to f8 display change you're
probably well familiar with this sort of
thing and we'll come over to the
optional parameter multiple machining if
that's not visible you can always arrow
over do your menu change and make sure
that all display is selected but once
you pick up multiple machine you can
close this and you notice that item
number 6 g 184 g 298 tapping mode can be
set to either floating or concurrent the
factory will send the machine with this
as a floating tap
and if you intend to use 184 as a rigid
tap definitely change it over to
concurrent so that now 178 and 184 will
both be rigid tap cycles the question
comes up usually when I explain this to
customers why would you need a special
cycle for a floating tap isn't it
exactly the same as a rigid tap and my
answer is I don't know somebody who's
well above my paygrade thought of that
but I always right off the bat will
change everyone's machine to rigid tap
for G 184 and you know if you've got a
floating holder in there so what what
pewdie it's still gonna do exactly the
same thing but by doing by flipping that
parameter now you can use either of
those codes all right we chose to use G
184 for this and I am going to delete
the additional holes so that you guys
can see a little something special here
in our G 184 line we're still going to
have our x RZ we're gonna knock that
down because we don't need to go as we
don't need to go as deep as this the
drill otherwise we're gonna bottom out
that tap we still have our our see
actually see the speak too early we
still have our see right there and we
have our K that's the same we don't need
the L value but we do want boop doop
doop doop we want a feed rate and in our
case that feed rate we're going to make
one / threads per inch multiplied by the
spindle rpm so in this case that's seven
point
eight one two five this is 1/32 x 250
there's our feed rate and the last value
that I want to put in here to show you a
little time-saver
so if you put a Q value in there that Q
is the number of holes in a 360 degree
bolt circle by simply putting that Q 4
in there it's gonna tap all four of the
holes how Nikki is at now one little
footnote for you if you decide to use G
178 the codes are almost the same but
instead of a feed rate you can put an F
of one indicating that there's only one
lead and add a J that includes the the
threads per inch so in our case if we
put f 1 j 32 it would then basically do
an inches per revolution instead of
inches per minute and we wouldn't have
to calculate out our feed rate let's see
how that looks shall we select and quit
save it and we'll come back up to our
main operating screen let's go back to
our animated simulation turn on the
program will do a where to go oops I'm
not an automatic mode that would be a
problem now that I'm in Auto I should be
able to restart at n 5 make sure I am
graphics in effect
Shh there's my holes oh I meant to turn
off the trace there we go
now let's do sequence restart turrets
enabled and here comes our rigid tab
a couple of notes about rigid tap on
Akuma cycles it's really neat if I were
to hit feed hold in the middle of the
tapping cycle she noticed that the
Machine did not stop it also did not
continue to the bottom of the hole like
some some of the other brand machines
if you hit feed hold when you're in a
tapping cycle across the board with
Akuma's it'll automatically reverse that
tool pull it out of the hole and then
stop and when I resume by hitting cycle
start it'll just start the process over
again some of the other machines if you
look up and you notice that oh I made a
mistake it's gonna go too deep and you
hit feed hold it says you know what
forget you let's I'm gonna wait until I
get to the bottom of the hole well the
bottom of the hole isn't deep enough so
you just broke a tap but at any time
during the rigid tap cycle if I hit feed
hold the tap turns around it backs out
that's that's a really cool feature I
use an awful lot right and then we go
home and we're in and one stop that's
reset now we'll go on to the next
process
and by calling up our process she will
see that after face tap we're gonna do
the face contour this is one of the hate
of the most handy cycles that the the
c-axis machine has and probably because
of that it is probably one of the more
difficult cycles to explain so let's see
how well I can do with this I'm going to
copy over the live to link call up and
bring it down to where it belongs and
paste it I don't remember what the tool
number is so let's call up our tool list
and find that our live z half inch end
mill
is tool number nine let's change this up
to be nine by nine - oh nine nine nine
we're doing six digits here because
we're going to expect this thing to be
able to compensate for the diameter of
the tool so we will call this Finch
email m8 and 110 and let's give this a
nice robust 4500 rpm that should be fine
for a real nice wicked tool like this
okay here's an extra code that we have
not used yet I want to shift the machine
from the plane that it's normally in the
working plane on a normal two axis lathe
is X and Z we already have figured that
out but I need to shift this into a
plane where I'm speaking to it in X&Y
terms which is g17 I believe we have
that out on our g-code list
I'll add it by the time you get there
g17 is XY g18 is X Z and g19 is Y Z it's
pretty much standard for CNC machines
across the board but the two that I
remember most Archie 17 and G 18 because
those two are the ones I use most
frequently okay I'm gonna get rid of
this positioning move because I want to
talk a little bit about what we are
about to do the if the process that
we're going to use is it seems
complicated but the machine wants to
work with us in terms of how to speak to
it I can't possibly expect to be
understood if I try to say hey I want
you to make this hex and I want you to
rotate the z-axis to synthesize a Y if
that's just way too confusing so what
the what the builders have put in here
is a cycle that will allow us to talk to
the machine in coordinates of X and Y
and the machine will respond by moving
the x axis and the C axis to synthesize
this so here's our our hex which by the
print is 1/3 what we decide it was let's
find my front imprint there it is so
it's 1 350 across the flats now there's
no trigonometry help on this machine I
still went and drew up a hex that's 1
350 across the flats so that I could
find each individual corner
that's that's about the hardest part of
my job when it comes to running this
particular cycle is finding those points
to point now you'll also notice that
this is X 675 that's X minus 6 75 so one
350 but it's not speaking in diametrical
values anymore Okuma knows that that can
be a little confusing so once we shift
into this magic milling mode it is gonna
automatically reduce the x axis to a
radial value so it matches the y that
may seem a little confusing or why do
you do that but once you start milling
oh yeah okay gotcha I don't have to
remember that even though this is X
positive 675 I don't have to go and
double it because of it being a
diametrical value nope it's just a plain
old mill so we will Mike the reason I
launched into that big ol segment is
because the first thing I want to do is
to move to a clearance position as we've
always done but this one is going to be
a diametrical value because we haven't
shifted into milling mode yet or the
what they call coordinate conversion I
don't want my use of the term milling
mode to get confused with m110 which is
of course milling mode so instead of
calling this milling mode I'm gonna call
this coordinate conversion mode so I
want to make a move that's expressed as
a diametrical value because we're not in
a coordinate conversion mode yet I'm
just gonna move to a nice safe distance
a good three inches off the part and
we'll go ahead and zero out our C
although that's not required I just like
doing it and we'll move to AZ clearance
plane that's up above the top of the
part now we will see when I go to
graphically verify this that this Z move
is critical because the machine is going
to make some fancy some pretty funky
moves when we engage this coordinate
conversion mode and so I want to make
sure that I'm well above the part I
added an extra extra 150,000 there just
so that hey alright I can be nice and
clear so now I am sitting above the part
and I'm ready to start milling spindle
speed is turning and I'm first move I
want to express to the Machine that hey
I want to engage that fancy coordinate
conversion cycle that Charlie's been
talking about gee 137 I do have an
explanation of this right on top and we
did everything we did go to engage
coordinate conversion mode and then
we're gonna program the profile in x and
y coordinates mindful that X is now a
radial move and if you are making a g1
move it will now be G 101 if you're
making a g2 move it will now be G 102 g
103 so we're just going to add one zero
in front of all of our G one two and
three motions and here's a nice
explanation of precisely what it's doing
but let's talk about it as it applies to
our part with the G 137 I have the
opportunity to put a coordinate shift on
the
on the the feature I'll demonstrate that
once we're done with the entire part but
the way this is currently drawn corners
are right at the X zero which is very
very handy well if this were rotated say
sixty degrees now these points are much
harder - harder to calculate so this
core this global shift that can be put
in with the G 137 would allow me to
program as if it were oriented the way
you see it but it would output it
shifted by a certain amount
I know confusing it'll make sense here
in a little bit so stick with me I'm
just gonna currently say that my shift
value is zero so X is going to remain X
zero and not shift now I'm in coordinate
conversion and I am ready to take the
tool from where it is now which is
somewhere out up over the wild blue
yonder and I'm going to feed it to where
I want to start the cut not touching the
part because as I described a few
minutes ago G 137 is going to cause some
pretty strange motion to occur as the
machine moves its axes to synthesize
what we want so my first move G 101 is
clearance move and I'm gonna put it to X
oh let's give it ten thousandths
basically what I'm wanting to do here is
I'm gonna position the tool up above the
part up here but I don't want to put it
right on X zero because I want to engage
cutter compensation and anytime you're
engaging cutter comp and a milling
cutter on an Akuma it's always best to
express both axes that are being comped
at the same time if you don't do that
you have the possibility that the one
axis that is moving will be comped the
second axis will not be comped until
after it makes contact with the part
and when programming by hand I I just
don't want to take that chance
so X point zero one and let's take this
to Y one point five I know this is a
radial value now so maybe I should go a
little less than that to like one point
four and so it will have moved off of
the the clearance position will have
moved into a radial radial engagement
and I'm gonna give it a big high feed
rate because again we're just
positioning at this point I think
somebody will should probably pipe up
and say hey wait a second wait a second
way to say it if you're positioning why
did you choose to do a fast feed 150 and
achieve 101 why didn't you just g0 out
there the reason behind that is that the
the G 137 can cycle does not want to do
any rapid moves it knows that hey you
may be able to tell me to g0 x is 1 y 2
and in theory that's easy but I have to
move this rotary axis like crazy to make
that happen so the the rule is that when
you're in G 137 there are no G zeros
don't use it it will alarm out so you
want to use if it's a positioning move
just use G 101 and make sure that your
feed rate is good and high so it will
it'll move it a good clip now I can G 1
- Z - let's go to 50 so it's passed that
lip oh goodness now somebody's got a
holler and say wait a second wait a
second how come you use G 101 here and G
1 here
well G 101 is defined as coordinate
replacement I'm speaking to it in x and
y but it's gonna respond in x and c so
they want g 101 there is no access
replacement for z it's still going to
move in z just as described so see when
by itself will be g 1 we're not
expecting it to replace that axis
whoo clear as mud right now we'll shift
back into G 101 I'm going to engage my
cutter compensation on this line because
we're about to move into the part and
I'll tell it to go to this point right
here which is X 0 by y 0.77 94 and give
it a feed rate of say 35 inches per
minute by the way even though this is
coordinate conversion it is going to be
moving so that the tool is achieving 35
inches a minute so it's going to move
the C axis faster or slower than then
the oppose the mating axis X so that it
achieves a surface tool footage of 35
inches a minute and also you notice that
I went right to this coordinate even
though we know that's the center of a
half-inch tool don't try to overthink it
and add in a quarter inch to that
because we've already done that in our
tool setup and G 41 is compensating for
that edge of the tool so now let's just
go through and I don't have to repeat G
101 because it's modal right here and
I'll just go through and name each
individual point as we go through X
point 675 by Y point 38 97 next move
will be
X point 675 that was modal I didn't
really have to repeat it in fact let's
let's not even put it in there let's
let's save a little space minus point 38
97 then we'll go back to X 0 by Y minus
point 7 7 94
X minus 0.67 five by Y minus thirty
eight ninety-seven our X is still going
to remain 675 so now we're going to go
to Y positive point 38 97 and our final
move is going to be back to X 0 by Y
point seven seven 94 now let's get the
heck off of the part and I'm gonna go
back to I'm gonna go back to where I
started this value right here with the
g42 cancel the cop X point zero 1 by y 1
point 4 now I will have moved well off
the part and cancelled my cutter
compensation so now I'll go to zero
point two five and let's give that a
fast feed we'll just get it the heck out
of the way so now I'm completely done
with this cycle and I'm ready to cancel
the coordinate conversion mode that's
with G 136 now we're back to a normal X
diametrical value and C is a decimal
degree instead of the calculation it's
supposed to make let's do a rapid to get
the heck away from the part 0.5 just to
say I did and we'll shut off our shut
off our tool I'm now out of milling mode
C axis is disconnected I'm going to put
in Ag 18 to return the active plane to X
Z and now G 0 X 30 z10 and M 1
let's see how we did save that bring
this up turn on our program now I'll
warn you ahead of time that when we do
this you're gonna see the same the same
feature that we witnessed during the
drilling cycle in that the part is not
going to move it will walk the tool
around it but at least we'll be able to
see that our part is correct and then
we'll run over into the machine and I'll
show you how it works so there's our
restart tool comes in mix cut up the
side
looking pretty good boom alright so now
that we've seen what it looks like in
graphics let's go ahead and flip over
and see what it looks like in the
machine where the material is actually
moving instead of just the part let's
run over to my collision-avoidance and
once again I'm going to find the happy
angle and that should be enough and
we'll move this over up and zoom just a
bit and let's do just a wee bit there we
go nice and centered and now we will run
through the process on super speed
okay now we're ready to do our milling
process I'm going to slow this down so
that we can talk while it's doing it
let's slow it way down now here comes my
tool notice the motion that it's making
while I'm up in the air this is that
positioning move that I described as
being pretty funky how the tool dipped
in and then dipped back out so that's
why we start far away from the part and
up above so it'll do that funky move
before it comes into the end of the part
now you notice how it's even though we
wrote X&Y it's reacting in X and C and
making our part exactly the way we
wanted it okay so now we've seen how the
Machine does it there's one more there's
one more thing I want to show you and
this is regarding that C shift pattern
that we saw so we see that these flats
are currently oriented so that two of
the holes in fact let's do a little
let's do a little facing action so that
so that we can look right down the face
of the part two of the holes were
oriented right along the flat of the
part yeah where'd my material go so
there's my material
why is it running the part off tool I
did a boo-boo all over again
that's it I'm fired okay so two of the
holes were oriented along the flats and
two of them were oriented at the points
so what I wanted to show you was that
the hex pattern was easy for us to
program when it was oriented the way we
just saw but let's say for instance that
that hex is supposed to be clocked to
the holes and have it offset by oh I
don't know let's say let's give it like
thirty degrees so we'll change this to
be C of thirty and now let's go in here
turn on our program and do a sequence
restart at n9 let it buzz through the
quick stuff okay there's our holes
there's the tapping action alright so
now we're gonna restart it and recall
that the flat used to be oriented here
with points here and here that coincided
with the with the holes now that I've
added a 30-degree shift
Zoop
now you notice it's off ever so slightly
it's no longer set exactly where it was
now the now the points are that used to
be aligned along here are now aligned up
here it'll probably probably would be a
little easier to understand if I did a
15-degree but I think you get it
we can shift the C axis based on where
the grid is
just to make it logical for us to
program in a certain fashion so let's
change this back to C 0 since our print
is calling that out and I believe we are
ready to save this and now we can move
on to our final process which is
drilling the outside holes okay so now
we're back to our final process before
we do the cut off and there we go the
side drill let's take a look at our
print and see what we've got we've got
called out one in three-quarter inches
from the face of the part we're gonna
have quarter inch by quarter inch ninety
degrees from each other and we're
fortunate enough to have them oriented
on the the quadrant so let's do this I'm
gonna call up the copy over my tool call
copy copy copy copy
and bring it to end at the bottom and
paste it soup and we'll change our
sequence numbers we have all along 1111
whoops one more and this is now an
x-axis live drill of 250 and obviously X
1 inch is no longer going to be
satisfactory so let's go say let's give
it a good clearance all the way out
above the raw stock of the part and I'm
still gonna go to the the Z clearance
plane just so that I can see that the
tool is gauged properly you know that
that's pretty much a running theme for
me here and now after that's done I'll
go to my Z location just to kind of
position things and now I don't want to
start pecking all the way out at 3
inches so let's drop this down - OH
- 750 now we're ready for our x-axis
Peck drilling cycle here is a really
neat feature that kuma has done for us
the Peck drilling cycle that we used for
the z axis and the Peck drilling cycle
that we used for the x axis is exactly
the same with one exception let's go
ahead and get up here and we will copy
our G 183 the Peck drilling cycle bring
it over to our 2 - 2
X cycle and paste it and let's talk
about what each one of these do again
our target point that should be the
since we're pecking in X we want to
change the the X target point to be our
two two and a half minus 250 per side so
that's going to be X two inches on let's
go a little deeper let's just go one
point nine fifty so we'll do 25
thousands deeper that is a diametrical
value because we're not doing G 137 and
our Z is of course wherever we were in
this case one point seven five C is
still zero but the K that we previously
specified is indicating to the machine
not just the retract plane as I
described in the face drilling cycle but
the letter that's used here is how the
Machine decides whether you're pecking
in X or in Z I and K are the two hot
tickets let's see if we can let's see we
can find our G 183 cycle oops that's a
little too big
and to do I didn't put the description
in there
but if we specify the letter I it's
going to pack in the x-axis as you see
it if you specify K it knows to peck in
the z-axis so instead of being K point
two five we're going to be an I've al
you and since we don't have that
counterbore to dip in let's just say Oh
eyes II wrote which will mean that it's
gonna start the cycle at the two point
seven five yeah that's a little much
there we go so now it'll start a hundred
thousandth in from that diametrical the
L value is our yeah we're gonna leave
that up so it'll short retract all the
way in there's our D and as we learned
with the G 184 rather than repeat for
repeat the process for C 90 C 180 C 270
we'll just do the Q throw in a Q value
and now it will now it'll make the the
four four holes equally spaced about 360
degrees and then well now that we're
done with the cycle will cancel it
we will let's do a nice turn off the
spindle kind of thing and then we'll get
out of C axis mode and let's do our G 0
x 30 Z 10 m1 look good let's see how we
did I'm going to get rid of some of
these extra carriage returns now that we
are in theory finished with our to
access program and we'll do our
selecting the quit whoops looks like
we're running something that's a that's
a good thing to point out now I'm glad
we had this little issue
when I tried to select and quit I get
this error that popped up this is main
program execution and I'm sure if any of
you out there have had control time
you've had this pop up before and make
you scratch your head what in the world
is going on if I look over here and look
at my machine there's not really
anything going on that I can tell turn
on my program and look at this I'm
sitting at an optional stop so the
control is currently processing
something whether it's a the leftovers
of an MDI command or the program is
still sitting even though the machine
wasn't moving the control was still
executing a program so when you try to
select and quit it's telling you exactly
that your main program is currently
executing so all you got to do is make
sure that the machine isn't physically
doing something reach up and hit the
reset button and now we can select and
quit boom no problem all right let's
turn on our program let's find our
restart we're gonna skip to and 11 make
sure that our graphics are turned on
okay do I restart now the x-axis is here
and I won't beat that dead horse but
you'll notice right off the bat oh look
at this
haha there's a little issue that came up
this is um this is one that you guys may
experience accidentally from time to
time and another fortunate incident that
we had if you read the alarm and it says
bad direct use of character I don't know
what that means it's blinking Z minus
1.75 I can get a description of this
alarm when the red bars on the top of
the screen if I come down to the soft
keys you'll see that right next to the F
buttons you got this little guy that
looks like a thought bubble
if you push that one it will open up the
manual right to the the alarm manual and
it'll take you right to the page that
describes the alarm that's on the screen
right now and here's a little something
that not a lot of people know if you if
you look down at I'm just gonna pick any
alarm here this one will work if you
look at the end of your alarm bar if
you're lucky there will be a number here
and the number corresponds to the line
of the programming or the alarm manual
that directly relates to what we what
our problem is in this particular case
it's giving us a hexadecimal code which
doesn't help but it's saying program
direct use of character 7a well there's
not a 7a in here so yeah hexadecimal
ASCII code it's just telling me that
illegal symbols are designated so now we
learned that a we can open up the alarm
manual by using the little happy bubble
but it says that there's something on
this line that's not correct z minus
1.75 it looks all good to me but let's
go program
open that up and this is something that
you guys may do accidentally when you
start getting getting good at typing at
the control there is a button on I can't
show you the button because I don't have
a picture of your keypad but there is a
cap lock button that's right next to I
can't even remember what key it is but
if you look there is a button on your
keypad that's dedicated to caps lock by
default when you power on the machine
caps lock will be on and it'll stay on
until somebody's typing quickly and
winds up inadvertently hitting that caps
lock key so if we that's exactly what I
did if you notice that Z son of a gun
it's lowercase that one's upper that
one's lower so I typed a lowercase Z and
the control does not know how to how to
handle a lowercase Z even if the
lowercase were in a operator note it
will say what what I don't know what
that is and generate the alarm now that
I made an uppercase we should be alright
so
one more thing for you if you look in
this upper yeah you guys can see that I
just wanted to make sure that I wasn't
cut off if you look on the upper portion
of your of your control you'll see that
the caps lock is highlighted and if I
take it off now it's gray so if you have
a piece of code that looks good and you
don't understand what's up first thing I
do is look up here and check well make
sure caps lock is on all the time the
only time it ever comes off is if
somebody's monkeying around with Windows
or they inadvertently hit the key
okay so auto mode let's do this all over
again our program is showing let's do a
restart at in 11 okay let it buzz
through now some of you may have also
noticed that on the previous run when
you're doing the rapid graphics like
this it doesn't change the color of the
cut plus that that the hex didn't get
cut by the by the end mill sometimes
particularly on milling processes if the
tool is moving too fast it it kind of
buzzes over in the graphics it happens
don't stress we saw the tool come out
and we know that it's good from when we
ran not in restart
boom there's our X Y & Z move to do tube
two and once again you saw the tool move
around the outside of the part but we
know full well that it's going to do it
right
Wow let's take the time to prove it
shall we
I've got 30 seconds to you
Oh looks like our part now we were going
through the part off that was programmed
in the two axis portion we already know
this works pretty well but let's go
ahead and let it cut all the way off
we'll watch the parts catcher deploy
and almost there we go there's our parts
catcher
we will chunk the thing all the way down
make a little angle change so we can see
that there's our profile and there's our
holes at the quadrants everybody's happy
how do we do we got a part made